let's talk about will ferrell and john c
reilly they are reunited for their new
movie Holmes and Watson and when they
sat down they'll give us a big clue
about their next project which has
something to do with taking my job hello
everyone this is Will Ferrell I'm joined
by mr. john c reilly Kevin Frazier
should be here guess he's got bigger
fish to fry thanks Kevin
won't ever forget it these are the
questions I've always wanted to ask
we've done a ton of movies together how
are we not sick of each other yet I
think just because we genuinely like
each other
I don't and we're careful not to outstay
our welcome with each other we both have
demonstrative signals to each other like
I don't know I can't even with you right
now okay let me see this face just try
it out okay go tit for tat yeah and ask
you a question what is the one question
you've always wanted to ask me oh well
do you fancy yourself a sportsman at all
well thank you for that question a great
answer what I just wanted to know what
the question was
oh let's talk about this movie Holmes
why should people go see our movie how
would you sum cuz it's ridiculous oh you
done with Cheryl why Watson I never left
if you like Sherlock Holmes we make all
kinds of jokes about the stuff that's in
Sherlock Holmes stories right if you
don't know the show it comes you don't
like him there's still enough there
money there would you mind if we had a
picture together who's going to take the
photograph I will take it hey we're
solving a royal family murder mystery in
this movie in buckingham palace do you
personally geek out about the royal
family in real life I think there's a
little part of all of us that geeked out
about the Royals whoo to sneak in to the
Queen's bedroom and put on silver jewels
and walk around a negligee right sneaked
through the hole
why do I feel like we will see will very
soon in the Queen's clothing Holmes in
watts it opens up Christmas Day
[Music]